i'm not sure that's the best
demonstration of what it's like to shave
your balls but i had fun doing it
if you've watched any youtube or listen
to any podcasts within the last few
years you've probably heard of manscaped
they're a company that specializes in
men's grooming tools this is their
lawnmower 3.0 and i hear about it on
podcasts all the time but i'm always
wondering to myself
how well does it work so i sent one of
these to myself and two hairy friends
and today we are going to be trying
manscaping
i've done this before actually for a
roll i got in a movie i shaved my chest
what i remember was that it
kind of hurt and then it growing back
really
felt weird i have shaved my chest before
but it was very old school italian just
a knife and you whack at
it but i am excited about it i've never
shaved my chest and i've never
you know properly done a manscaping
this came with a lot of instructions and
i'm not gonna read them
um i don't have that much chest hair
obviously i'm uh
not the hairiest man in the world and it
grows in weird patterns all right
remember last time i like cut my nipple
so i'm gonna be very gentle i'm gonna go
over there
ah see do it again ah that hurts oh
you're supposed to shave
up they said so
slow and steady wins the race i'm trying
to get an arrow right down the middle
oh that feels good that's fast through
oh i keep hitting my nipple
oh boy that's a lot of hair honestly
this is real smooth so far
oh hey will i knew i'd be walking into
something
i'm scared of shaving off my nipple this
is
really good quality shave
i could collect all these hairs and give
it as a gift
as a light in case you want to shave in
the dark yeah it's just so quick
and see the thing you get you get razor
burn it's not bad it's not as bad as the
other one i feel like my chest is like
blazing red by that other one under here
now under here oh god you're right
thanks couldn't see the hair cuz my uh
you know this feels pretty good it's
like it's short enough that it's
definitely made an impact but not all
the way down and i'm not worried that
i'm gonna get razor bumps
it is still a bit itchy but now i feel
lopsided i feel like i'm going to fall
over this way
those look like cockroaches
always do your belly button that was
really quick i was like
under five minutes that's like
remarkable honestly i gotta shave my
stomach now
where does chest hair end and pubes
begin
give me a second i'm gonna go to uh take
care of another part
i'll report back soon obviously i can't
show us actually
shaving down there but for demonstration
purposes i have this patch of fake grass
i'm gonna shave
to really show off the lawn mower in
action first i'm gonna try shaving
straight
and then i'm gonna make a little crevice
to show what it's like shaving around
those
pesky corners and here is the freshly
mowed lawn
this is where the crevice was i'm not
sure that's the best demonstration of
what it's like to shave your balls but i
had fun doing it
i just got done shaving the basement i
feel 10 years lighter i feel a hell of a
lot smoother and overall i just feel
better
i am done with down there again really
fast really efficient process
and i finally got rid of the forbidden
forest that had been growing on
my body that was one of the better
experiences i've had shaving things down
there way better than using scissors
and like i've tried using just like a
razor before and it's not
good just before we start recording my
my partner said wow you look so weird
bear chested so
that's great thanks gotta grow out of
that now it feels really good though it
feels smooth
i like the way it looks i feel like a
swimmer i'm pretty happy with this
little guy
a link to it will be available in the
description below it's definitely a
little bit pricier than some of the
other
trimmers that i've seen but this is the
first time i've ever done anything down
there without it being itchy afterwards
so if that's all this gave me
then i would be satisfied so i guess
those podcasters know what they're
talking about
hmm